mic plans to build a porch with the
floor plan below in order for the porch
to be up to city code it cannot have a
perimeter that is greater than 300 feet
let me underline that it cannot have a
perimeter that is greater than 300 feet
or another way to think about it the
perimeter has to be 300 feet or less
find the perimeter of the porch using
the floor plan below and determine
whether or not its perimeter meets the
city's code requirements all right so we
need to find the perimeter of this porch
and just as a reminder the perimeter is
the distance around the object or
another way of thinking about it it's
the sum of the lengths of the sides of
the object so to find the perimeter of
this porch we just have to add up these
lengths of the different sides so let's
do that so we're gonna have a 40 we're
going to add up 40 plus 20 plus 55 plus
30 plus 95 plus 50 plus 50 and we're
adding just to make sure we know what
we're doing and we make sure we've
aligned them by place which we've done
here the ones places are all aligned the
tens places are all aligned so now let's
start on the ones place
what is zero plus zero plus five plus
zero plus five plus zero well that's
really just the same thing as 5 plus 5
which is 10 right the zero carry the 1
or another way of thinking about it
regroup the one which is really a 10
right it's it's 10 the one in the tens
place literally represents or the 10 so
we put it in the tens place and now we
add up all of the tens places so we have
1 plus 4 is 5 plus 2 is 7 plus 5 is 12
plus 3 is 15 plus 9 is 20 4 plus 5 is 29
so the total perimeter of Mike's porch
ears 290 feet which is less than it is
less than 300 feet so it meets the city
code it could have even been equal to
300 feet so we could have even said it
just has to be less than or equal to 300
feet and we meet our city code so he can
go ahead and build this porch